good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-2901
object class
euclid
special containment procedures
because of the extra-dimensional
properties related to scp-2901
there are currently no methods of
physical containment case reports
involving
scp-2901 will be remitted to mobile task
force 5-5 twilighters for further
investigation
civilian sightings of scp-2901 will be
suppressed using amnestic field
applications media leaks regarding
scp-2901 will be deleted or discredited
by the information detraction censorship
and rescission division id card
field personnel should avoid scp-2901
if at all possible those authorized to
investigate
scp-2901 must carry mobile devices
capable of short message services sms in
case of sudden acoustic cancellation if
a hostile encounter is unavoidable
personnel should adhere to the following
steps
number one do not attempt to run fleeing
may provoke scp-2901
to give chase
number two hold your ground be sure to
make eye contact
number three make a threat display using
clothing to imitate an increase in body
mass
number four continue step three until
scp-2901 becomes disinterested and
submits
number five avoid physical contact if at
all possible wield or throw objects to
maintain distance
description
scp-2901 are a species of nocturnal
carnivorous scavengers of limited
intelligence averaging 1.7 meters in
height
scp-2901 usually appear as having an
ellipsoid shape and possess two large
eyes layered with photophoric tissue
scp-2901 are covered in a layer of
minute iridescent lamellar scales
similar to lepidopterans scp-2901
are able to move through space-time
freely granting them certain abilities
such as levitation flight and
teleportation
scp-2901
are however tangible and susceptible to
conventional firearms
scp-2901 are also able to emit an
acoustic cancellation effect within a
radius of approximately 25 meters the
purpose or function of this ability is
not wholly understood but it is
theorized to aid in stealth
several methods of containment and or
deterrence are still being considered
however because of the elusiveness of
scp-2901
a large majority of the general public
are aware of related incidents and
possibly even the existence of scp-2901
counter-measures are in place as a
temporary solution for protecting
information on scp-2901
level two access required
id card information detraction
censorship and rescission division id
card scp foundation.internet x 7502
fax
7503
operation surgeon's photograph
priority dollar
internal use only
pre-humble
due to the uncontainable nature and
general notoriety of scp-2901
certain protocols must be established in
order to quell civilian suspicion as to
the existence of these entities the
following is an outline of operation
surgeon's photograph that should be
reviewed by your respective teams
counter intelligence
due to the nature of operation surgeon's
photograph information regarding
scp-2901 does not require additional
safeguards against espionage information
about scp-2901 will remain accessible on
the foundation main list database
standard protocols for sensitive
information access clearance and storage
still apply
identification of sensitive material
utilizing the automated virtual agents
already in place the certain keywords
related to scp-2901 will be routinely
searched and red flagged on the daily
reports pages will be reviewed by
selected teams as they are discovered
and remitted to the tactical planning
team to determine the severity and next
course of action
disinformation campaign
the tactical planning team will review
suspected files or pages and make
decisions and recommendations regarding
pertinent threats dozens of online dummy
accounts for media sharing websites are
to be created and managed by id cards
special cyberspace unit using these
dummy accounts content regarding the
presence and or glorification of
scp-2901
will be made widely available this is to
saturate any shared leaked footage or
images with fabricated disinforming
content content will be developed and
published in a variety of mediums
related to
scp-2901 including fictional stories
doctored photographic images visual
semi-realistic art falsified eyewitness
interviews and merchandise
the foundation front company studio city
productions will be contracted to create
several low-budget documentaries
involving scp-2900
while including other well-known
cryptids from folklore this will further
aid in convincing the general public
that the existence of scp-2901
is highly questionable and in all
likelihood impossible
to validate
required deletions
any source material of scp-2901
deemed too sensitive to be accessible to
civilians will also be addressed by the
special cyberspace unit standard
protocols for denial of service
operations will be carried out to
isolate the source after the source is
isolated efforts will be made to erase
the original content any information
regarding the original poster of the
material will then be handed over to
mobile task force 55 for further
investigation
in all cases services will be restored
once the material has been erased any
denial of service operations in excess
of 24 hours will need to be reported to
the department of external affairs
cessation of operations
operation surgeon's photograph will
continue until a viable method of
containment or deterrent for scp-2901
is in place virtual agents will continue
to search for keywords related to a
cp2901
these will be included on the month and
reports to be reconciled at the end of
the quarter content made during
operation surgeon's photograph will
remain accessible
the first official documented incursion
of scp-2901
was near the town of
west virginia usa in 19
followed by the collapse of
since then continuing field observations
have concluded that scp-2901
are an aggressively territorial and
solitary species
scp-2901 normally do not engage or
reveal themselves openly to humans and
will often retreat or vanish if
discovered
further observations suggests that
scp-2901 are able to approximate the
time and location of future disasters
with a certain degree of accuracy
particularly those resulting in multiple
fatalities this is supported by accounts
and reports showing a sudden presence of
scp-2901 within the vicinity of the
disaster area usually within a month or
week before it occurs
during this period many scp-2901 will
claim rights to the area resulting in
altercations with other scp-2901
sometimes including human bystanders
being mistaken as threats during these
aggressive territorial behaviors
scp-2901 are able to change their
physical shape into a large
nebulous-like body as a threat display
after the disaster event occurs the
remaining
scp-2901 will take part in feeding off
the deceased in a frenzy-like behavior
until the food source is depleted
vacating once satiated
level 4 access required
id card
information detraction censorship and
rescission division id card scp
foundation.internet x7502
fax
7503
confidential priority gimbal
directive
operation surgeon's photograph is to be
considered the special containment
procedures for scp-2901
and is to operate under the guise of an
active public disinformation campaign
mobile task force 55 will be responsible
for its continuation and level of
effectivity in maintaining acceptable
levels of public awareness and
conception
as a point of clarification the purpose
of operation surgeon's photograph is not
to protect information on scp-2901
but rather control information on
scp-2901
summary
scp-2901's current evolution is the sum
of foundation's efforts in manipulating
its existence through public perception
scp-2901 are a group of
extra-dimensional entities that lack a
stable cohesive form and purpose that
only coalesces through continued
observational reconciliation for
scp-2901 to maintain a stable physical
mass approximately 75 of the nearby
human populace within 500 kilometers
need to be congruent on a singular
concept of what scp-2901
is
and what it does
scp-2900 were first discovered and
categorized as highly unstable cataclas
entities capable of producing localized
ck-class scenarios at random further
research into scp-2901's
unstable manifestation proved to be
futile as unbeknownst to foundation
scientists at the time
scp-2901 would involuntarily change
during each subsequent observation
during a containment breach into the
civilian populated areas within the
appalachian region of the southern
united states
scp-2901 began gradually condensing into
a singular manifestation the more it was
exposed to humans
civilians began conceding to the idea
that scp-2901 was a dark wing-like
humanoid with large red eyes which
corresponded to the pre-existing local
folklore
scp-2901 also began to evolve
predatory-like behaviors and anomalous
acoustic effects that conceptualized
due to the mass fear generated within
the surrounding communities
foundation researchers recognized the
effects and began isolating
scp-2901 as much as possible however
deprived of regular perceptual input
scp-2901 began to devolve into its
initial highly unstable manifestations
once again the decision was made to
maintain scp-2901
in a functioning manageable state
through continued exposure to human
perceptual belief that
scp-2901 is a tangible creature of local
folklore another bigfoot or loch ness
monster
the nearby silver bridge collapse of
1967
and the
scp-2901 appalachian incursion and
reality have no connection with one
another however public opinion strongly
disagreed and henceforth
scp-2901 began to appear at other future
disaster events this was the precursor
of the precognitive scavenging
animal-like behavior that is observed
today
efforts are to continue gradually
introducing notions developed by the
foundation as to further
scp-2901's evolution into a more docile
and manageable concept
internal counter intelligence
only foundation personnel with level 4
clearance are permitted to view this
document for all intents and purposes
all other personnel are to be included
in actively contributing to
scp-2901's perceptual evolution it is
pertinent that this document be limited
to no more than 50 persons
including the o5 council
and that concludes today's lecture thank
you for listening if indeed you still
are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
allah trayon
zargaran
professor puffer
retalias
jk
signor
your local foundation agent
derivative
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
a real american hebrew
scio dio demnaris
eric corbige
longinus
karim el ashmoy
james saba
and nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you